jour aujourd'hui pour cette première
journée deux pages étaient autour des
sentiers de randonnée et du patrimoine
je vous retrouve à saint viâtre nous
sommes au coeur de la sologne des étangs
ici je vous fais découvrir en fait une
boucle particulière autour des étangs de
sologne une boucle nature autour de la
faune de la flore et à quelques pas de
moi se situe la maison des étangs c'est
le point de départ du sentier de
randonnée que je veux vous faire
découvrir aujourd'hui nous allons
rencontrer jean michel le baron qui est
guide nature à la maison des étangs qui
va nous raconter un peu le patrimoine
historique autour des étangs de sologne
pourquoi comment des étangs en sologne
mais tout d'abord je vais vous faire
découvrir le joyau de saint viâtre c'est
son église du viiie siècle et on se
retrouve juste après à saint viâtre le
monument le plus remarquable c'est
l'église construite entre le 8e et le
xviie siècle le bâtiment a traversé les
âges et subit aussi bien les
embellissements que les affres du temps
reconstruite en grande partie au 16e
siècle à cause d'un incendie ravageur
l'édifice accueille en 1520 un retable
qui retrace la vie de saint viâtre et
son passage en sologne et jean ont été
guéris et ici devant ce ce tarbes ce
tremble deux issues semble-t-il de du
circuit de saint viâtre qui était faite
de trembles et comme ils sont riches ils
promettent de construire à cet endroit
une église pour
perpétuer la mémoire de ce miracle dont
ils ont été l'objet au xvème siècle
la commune est le lieu de nombreuses
processions religieuses jusque-là
éphémère l'échafaud et construit en dur
pour accueillir les personnes illustres
de passage dans le village
ici il y avait une station avec une
petite cérémonie religieuse et à ce
moment là bas on demander tout ce qu'on
voulait à ce moment là soit soit le
bhoutan sur la pluie en fonction des
types de désiré et surtout aussi pendant
les épidémies
on demandait les guérisons et ça c'était
très important
l'église de saint viâtre recèle d'autres
trésors comme la crypte et un clocher
tors des anecdotes et des merveilles à
venir découvrir sur place tout l'été
de retour à l'étendue mouais on est avec
jean michel le baron ici on est en plein
coeur de la sologne des étangs c'est
bien ça et d'où viennent tous ces étangs
solognot c'est surtout la création de
l'homme en fait c'était une nécessité
c'est et en ont été réalisés depuis le
moyen-âge parce qu'il était nécessaire à
de fortes périodes de chaleur de d'avoir
de l'eau et à partir de là tout une
activité humaine s'est développée et
aussi une grande biodiversité aussi à
l'homme ç'a lui servait du coup
aussi bien pour lomé pour la
pisciculture pour les habits en fait
c'était un mode de vue à part entière de
vivre autour des étangs c'était c'était
voilà toute une activité certes mais à
partir de là ces hommes vont pouvoir
valoriser l'eau sous différentes
manières dont qui ont retrouvé bien sûr
la pisciculture
mais il y avait aussi qui était lié bien
sûr l'élevage et puis d'autres d'autres
métiers automatiquement mais plus
ponctuels comme les moulins à eau ou le
les tanneries entre autres et qui dit
main de l'homme dit forcément entretien
de ces étangs comment il s'était
entretenu basset et ans à partir du
moment où ils avaient de l'intérêt était
donc entretenu et donc la nécessité bien
sûr c'était d'éviter qu'il se comble
donc il y avait bien sûr l'envasement et
puis aussi après éviter l'impact de
certaines espèces qui ont été importés
comme les ragondins qui vont creuser des
galeries et derrière ça l'entretien a
été valorisé aussi par il mettait les et
en acier qui est d'être cultivé à
l'époque aussi d'accord donc il n'était
pas forcément tout le temps en nous
c'est bien ça c'est ça il y avait des
périodes d'une ou deux années où ils
pouvaient être mises en culture ce qui
permettait aussi de faire de très bonnes
récoltes aussi à l'occasion
et alors là quand on vient se promener
le promeneur en vélo à pied à cheval
qu'est-ce qui peut découvrir en était
autour des étangs de sologne
ça va être toute cette riche faune au
tour à 7,7 biodiversité de grand nombre
un grand nombre d'oiseaux on va avoir
aussi ce que ce que va rechercher
actuellement un petit peu les visiteurs
ça va être cette ambiance de paisibles
et de calme et de tranquillité et et
puis aussi la rue le retour à paunat la
nature ok merci beaucoup jean michel
c'est gentil merci de nous avoir un
petit peu expliquer tout ça toute
l'histoire des étangs de sologne
nous on se retrouve demain demain on
sera à taizé donc entre archéologie
ruines gallo-romaines et 20